well good morning everyone my name is
Peter Sora and I run engineering at
quantcast today would like to share with
you how would you forecasting on the
internet using large amounts of data one
gas is a net tech company and it has
several lines of business measure that
helps publishers websites of various
sizes understand the audience and
advertise that offer several advertising
products to market ears in this talk
I'll briefly describe how those two
products work and then we'll dive into
the modeling of machine learning which
basically we use for various forms of
forecasting at the end we'll share a
couple of fun trends that we've observed
with some of our publishing and
advertising customers
quantcast measure helps publishers
understand their audience and again by
publishers I mean basically website
owners as a customer Yelp on this
example you tag your website page and
then every time anybody visits your page
we record that event in an anonymous way
from the events we generate demographic
data and they will present that data to
Yelp in easy-to-understand set of tools
and capabilities in many cases the data
actually publicly available and anybody
including yourselves can go and check it
out if you come to quantcast com and
search for Yelp you'll see that about 31
million people visit their site weekly
and as you can see recently it's been
dominated by mobile traffic you see that
the audience is heavily indexes on
people between 25 and 35 years old Asian
Democrats with large income their
interests include food and drink not
surprisingly and they're 20 times more
likely to visit opentable.com than an
average internet population quantcast
matches a free product and a lot of
sites are using it and it's it's a
useful thing to understand who is your
audience who comes to your site
quantcast advertised works in a
following way we tagged a conversion
event on an advertiser's site for
example a purchase button on the flowers
site they have a model consumption
patterns of customers that purchase the
flowers and then based on those patterns
we identify ideal prospects on the
internet and then we target those
consumers at scale
it takes several components to be
competitive in this advertising industry
you have to have a global network to
collect events you have to have
significant transaction processing
infrastructure you have to have massive
computing power to process the data that
you collect and of course you have to
have machine learning expertise to
process that data at quantcast will have
18 globally distributed data centers and
we collect pixels and respond to ad
exchange requests using that
infrastructure it is a requirement both
in our measure and advertise side that
we respond within 100 milliseconds to
any side across the globe and that 100
milliseconds is actually measured by the
client and it measured both hops to the
to us and back so it actually includes
internet internet traffic we're
collecting process about two and a half
million transactions per second across
both our measure and advertise products
and we have thousands of nodes in our
MapReduce and life processing cluster
the process about 30 petabytes every
single day and we have about dozens of
engineers working on machine learning
problems we've lost nine years so let's
talk a little about machine learning
will show how quantcast built luka lack
models at internet scale first you need
a statistical model of Internet
quantcast measure is one of the dominant
audience measurement sites and literally
tagged hundreds of millions of websites
destination it observes of over 500,000
media consumption events every second
around the world and what I mean by a
media consumption event is someone like
us come to website and hit a website a
particular URL this data constitute a
behavioral model of the internet enable
machine learning models to basically
help publishers understand their their
audiences and find advertising prospects
for our advertisers
so what do we mean by a statistical
model of the internet we record features
and we record and feature eyes media
events for example when you come to a
website you have this cookie which is
the synonymous identifier of yourself
and then we track everything about that
cookie we record the time that day you
visit that site we record what site you
visit it we record the location you
visited from and there's a lot of other
features that we record about that one
cookie event and then we and then we
just basically create a graph of those
cookies and how they interact with the
media so for example this particular
example you can see that cookie with
this opaque number 25 66 etc visited
smiles calm we also see that that same
cookie visited cats video network then
we see that another cookie starts with
AAC visited actually was shown an ad and
also visited monster truck mobile
application with track actually events
across mobile as well as web that other
cookie lives in Brisbane Australia and
also visited smiles calm so the smiles
calm is event in common between those
two cookies and as a result we can
derive various different properties for
example maybe those cookies are similar
or maybe the site sighs calm smiles calm
and cats videos calm a similar sites
and then we do the demographics VI in
ferns so we start with that media that
we've tagged so we've tagged the media
media sites here in the right hand
column you can see that all those media
sensitive tag and then we actually use
panel data various different sources of
panel data and actually there's a lot of
complexity about how you make sure that
your panel data is not a bias towards
one or the other or something one of the
other thing but but essentially there's
panels involved in any of that modeling
and from panel data we actually know
that some cookies and panel is similar
and how we know that because those two
cookies in red visited kiddies calm and
the two cookies and blues visited
monster trucks calm and then we see that
news com Maya might not be similar to
monsters calm or not its proximity
indexes also matters and then we have a
set of anonymous cookies and it's
basically all of us that we collected
five hundred cookies for 500 events per
second and then we see that those
cookies visit kittens calm and they also
see they also see that those cookies
visit some other targeted media and so
we infer demographics of the anonymous
cookies based on demographics of panel
data
and so you can see that anonymous
cookies now have different colors
because of the strong similarities to
the cookies in the panel
then there is a audience similarity as I
mentioned so if you have if you have for
example if you have that connection
between the most a truck through the
cookies to football that biz you can see
that this to come these are the two
common visitors and they're connected by
by those two media nodes and then you
can see that in this particular example
8 hops have no common visitors so it's
probably no commonalities between
between those sites so in quantcast
advertised model training with as i
mentioned to you before we actually take
this this event that we tag on your
website on the conversion event what we
call for example a Thank You page or by
button somewhere and then we market
mover monitor those are tagged
conversion events then we score cookies
by closeness metric to each other so we
see that those cookies that convert it
they have similarities and then with
score media context by closest my
closeness metric saying that you know
your website is related to some other
media for example you know flowers calm
is are similar to flowers 800 calm or or
or some other some other website and
together they make a behavioral and
contextual model and of course reach of
the visit graph the better the closest
score metric
that's why the data is sighs actually
really matters you that's why you have
to collect a lot of data for this for
this modeling to work I can't stress
enough how how important the data set is
in this innocent is what seems pretty
simplistic model I really you know
mediocre algorithm running on a very
very large data set is is is a better
outcome than of sophisticated algorithm
larger than a small sample and so when
we do the scoring we score the entire
internet so we literally take the
population of billions of cookies and we
create a score for each of them as they
relate to each model of advertiser so
there's literally no bad cookie is just
the probability of event becomes slower
and slower and slower as the features of
the cookie over the cookie becomes less
and less similar to the feature of the
cookies that convert we use real value
scores real time values course when you
receive an event from a particular page
we put that event into the model scoring
in real time and the reason why we do
that is because cookies actually change
their behavior over time so really to
kind of to emphasize you know the more
data leads to better statistics and list
them more accurate scores so I want to
take an example to kind of explain the
point a little bit further and this this
is a real example in illustration in the
of a traveller site that with that is
our customer so what we first do we
define success so we put our tag which
is literally this little this little URL
you can see little 2 1 x 1 pixel image
on a page where you purchase a ticket on
the x button of an airline ticket and
then once that pixel is place we start
observing we just start recording events
from that page and we see that there's
two people bought these tickets you know
airline ticket by one and
too so we just observe those two cookies
and then we'll look up in our feature
store what events do we have associated
with those cookies so we see that the
first person likes the classical music
into sports particularly football and
basketball like art modern cameras
high-end travel foreign languages
fashion discount airline tickets of
course because they bought it the other
person likes cars and trucks
specifically trucks art museums travel
foreign language location is in san
diego real estate in multiple places etc
how do we know those cookies is because
of how do we know those features because
we feature eyes those through our
measure site right we create those
features and in fact this features a
tremendous space in fact there's
literally billions of features and if
you think about it our sparse model it
features about it's a matrix that is
about three to five million features in
the cookie space so it's scary to think
but we do have about say an average
hundreds of thousands of features per
individual cookie it's incredible the
density of information that is if you
have a significant significant volume of
data floating so then we
reverse-engineer the target audience so
the model again uses millions of those
of those features to create a score for
each of the feature so we see that in
this particular example art is a
significant contributor travel in
foreign language is a very significant
contributors score photography is
somewhat significant what is also
important is that we use the negative
signal and it's negative signals are as
important as a positive signals in the
model why they're important because when
you create a score in the in the model
when you actually look at the score you
see that we take the the model with this
course and we'll take the real time bid
request which is a context in which we
apply the model so it is to publish a
URL so when you look at a particular
page that you went to cnn.com and you
see the ad we receive that event from
CNN com when we actually bid on that on
that opportunity to display a net for
you we see who is the publisher that is
CNN com we see topics maybe they may be
visiting the food section we see the
local time we see the location where
you're coming from and we'll see the
behavioral information of that call that
publisher as well you know the music
romance movies etc etc and so each
request k is a probability of a
conversion and using that probability in
various pricing strategies in the bid
request we actually create score so what
is interesting is that we apply bids we
submit bids on every single opportunity
that comes to us and as I mentioned
earlier in the talk we have two and a
half million transactions per second
half a million of which is a measure
product and two million of which is
actually advertised product and what it
is is that it's a signal that we
received from all the stock exchanges
sir not stop the advertising exchanges
around the world and if they do want a
bid on this cookie do you want a bid on
this cookie they want to beat on that
cookie we score each and every single
one of them with the probability of
whether we believe that the cookie is
going to convert for a particular ad and
then we bid on that cookie we have an
internal auction in our own site where
we determine which which of the
customers of ours will benefit most from
that from that event and we bid on that
event we bid on every single one of them
cost somewhere between zero and a very
very small number per cookie so that's
basically how the modeling works on the
local ack modeling works where we use
its statistical model of the internet
that we get from our measure data and we
apply that on on events like advertising
but once you have the statistical model
of internet you actually can forecast
various different trends and sometimes
it's hard sometimes it's easy so I
wanted to show you a couple of
interesting trends that that you can
easily look at if your publisher and the
potentially the first time some behavior
information about by the population so
for instance let's take let's take a
look at this particular publisher which
is eHarmony Harmons the dating site in
fact all the publishers and my examples
are going to be associated with dating
various forms so here we see that right
off the bat we found something
interesting but comparing California
against it's the Seaboard we discover
this there is such a thing as right time
for males to visit to visit the Harmony
we also see that you have a higher male
to female ratio guys using a harmony in
California than in the East Coast it's
interesting it's sort of just floating
through by looking at the demographics
and time of day another interesting
example of sugar daddy for me calm it
looks like sugar daddies show up at that
site at 5am a woman of sleeping at that
time and largest concentration of women
show you up at three p.m. while
presumably sugar daddies are working and
it looks like sugar daddies go to bed
early so by by looking at that site you
can seek you know you the publishers
could figure out maybe there's a an
additional feature set like all flying
conversations that they could support
what have you and the other one is a
particular example you see a whole bunch
of dating websites and you see that if
you want to date a PhD it looks like
they're also going to be fit once
because most of PhDs show up on Fitness
signals signals signals zooming goals
sorry and and you can see there's a very
significant difference in in the in that
demographic on that side so forecasting
the sort of simple chance like that it's
pretty easy in the publisher site I
wanted to also talk to you a little bit
about how to forecast transient
advertising models and that's a lot
harder than the forecast and trends in
publishing and the reason for that is
because advertising models literally
look at millions of features scoring in
real time and here's one story of an
interesting complicated complicated
trend that took
a little time to figure out so there was
a campaign that we were running on
behalf of customer in June 2012
quantcast became to work with a
prominent airline company the goal of
the campaign was to increase sales on
specific crowds from to San Francisco
from around the country and the campaign
was supposed to run during the entire
month of June so quantcast set out to
find the travel enthusiasts who are
looking to book flights to San Francisco
during that time of June so what do we
found the one campaign begun we start
looking at the performance and
particularly on the sites that we
deliver the advertising and we pulled
the report and notice some really
surprising surprising information you
see that we found that there were
several other the majority of our ads
were showing at across dentist sites
something really had to be wrong with
with our models so we became to
investigate couldn't be right why would
we why would we advertise the dentists
so we have a lot of confidence in our
models to really pick the behaviors that
lead to conversions in a short window of
time in June 2012 the model decided that
the best place to sell airline tickets
was on dental sighs but why after a lot
of digging we found that it turned out
that American Dental Association was
hosting an annual conference in San
Francisco during October when that when
we learned that we realize that the
model has been right basically all along
so what does we really learn from that
model we figured out that the dentists
are careful planners and it looked to
book their travel months in advance the
they have hotel and airline booking in
October of confidence and they reach
that that peak and booking in June so
the model correctly determined that the
best way to increase sales for San
Francisco roots is to serve dentist go
into that conference
Headley campaign had different dates the
model would have been behaving
completely differently and shown the ads
in at different places so when you have
this when you have the statistical model
that looks at millions of signals
picking up and rationalizing why those
signals happens is a really difficult
and tricky thing and that's one example
why that is in fact this real-time
direct response advertising is very
different than the traditional
advertising which is brand advertising
where are a customer an advertiser
markets here comes to you and says look
you know I want to reach out 25 to 34
year old women that like string cheese
because I know that that's my
demographic audience the the truth is
actually very different the truth that
be that you know you're the audience
that really buys your product is
entirely different and so the models
really should show if this particular
example shows why that could be the case
so I hope that during this presentation
that they know I showed a few techniques
in predicting published in advertising
trans online using statistical models of
internet and now I would like to take a
few questions if you have any